[Music]
all right so the new leader oh really
the real speaker in Congress
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortez
is not resonating well with a lot of
voters we have a new Gallup poll it is
showing that although she is well known
now throughout the nation Acacio Cortez
is polling well fairly negatively maybe
it could be because there were radical
policies I kind of think so and also
tonight Acacio Cortez is saying it isn't
easy having to work all the time so hard
thirty years in radio 23 here's the Fox
ten years in construction ten years in
restaurants sorry she's working so hard
and take a look the thing they don't
tell you about working in Congress is
that you do what you're supposed to do
you're working all the time which means
that you have no time to like set up
your life so I spent weeks sleeping on
an air mattress and I don't own a chair
all right following the whirlwind of
backlash against the congresswoman in
this case Omar's anti-semitic statements
fellow freshman progressive
congresswoman to leave well she's now
being criticized for reportedly
supporting an effort to end colleges
study board program with Israel Wow we
reached out to congresswoman to leaves
office for comment but she's not getting
back to us here with reaction tonight
Fox News contributor we have former
congressman jason Chaffetz and also
joining us is a national press secretary
for the Trump twenty20 campaign Kaylee
mcenany congressman we start with you
tonight good to see you both affect your
reaction not only to this also to the
news steals what now we see in Steele's
testimony and what we learned in ORS
testimony and Paige's testimony
instructs testimony and McCain's aide
testimony this is now beginning to
crumble
look the fix is in from the beginning I
was the chairman of the Oversight
Committee we were trying to dig deep
into this we were stonewalled we were
obstructed we said they kept telling us
don't worry about it
then James Comey once he made this
announcement came and testified
before Congress you go line line by line
by that I'm telling you there are things
that he said under oath that are
flat-out lies that have been discredited
mr. Comey should be held accountable for
this he should be prosecuted for what he
did wait a minute he will you eat wait a
minute he signed off on the FISA
verifying the dossiers true McCabe no
dossier no FISA then he's telling
Trumpets unverified a few months later
did he lie to the FISA judges yes he did
lie to the FISA judges and he also lied
to the to the Oversight Committee under
oath when he came in told us oh it was
unanimous it was unanimous that we
didn't want to charge her meanwhile we
come to find out it was really somebody
pulling the strings at the Department of
Justice and this is where Congress needs
to hold them accountable and the people
have no authority Lynch for this
now that we know Loretta Lynch was up to
our eyeballs and rigging this what
happens at what should now happen to her
what they did I do believe there should
be either a special prosecutor put in
place to look at the malfeasance that
was happening within the Department of
Justice and within the FBI been calling
for that for months if they if you can
warrant to go after Donald Trump then
you look at what's going on the
senior-most etholon at the Department of
Justice and that far exceeds anything
that was even an allegation in the
Trump's situation Kaley yeah that's
exactly right you know the fix was in
from the get-go we learned from Lisa
Paige this week that in fact there was
an insurance policy against President
Trump we learned that from Peter
Struck's text again verified by Lisa
Paige's testimony there and this is
striking Sean I mean this is corruption
at the highest order we have to stand
against it and you compare that to the
way Hillary Clinton's been treated it's
outrageous this has been a witch-hunt
from the beginning and I would finally
add Andrew Weissman also stepping down
from the special counsel this week why
was this guy there to begin with who
costs 20,000 people their jobs and was
unanimously rebuked by the Supreme Court
congressman where is Horowitz where's
who buries in your home state what are
these guys doing why is this taking so
long
so Horowitz is the Inspector General for
the Department of Justice he's been
working on this for nearly a year
I do have believe some belief that
dentals take another month or two they
buried him in more than a million types
of documents but ultimately I think he
will be the key authority on this he has
looked at it and seen it much further
and wider than anybody else
I'm forged it's never fast enough Shawn
it's never ever fast of Hueber who's the
US Attorney for in Utah that was
appointed by sessions to overlook some
of this stuff absolutely no idea what
he's doing haven't heard word one and
most concerning is that the witnesses
that were put forward by Mark meadows
and Jim Jordan encouraged them to talk
they've never even been interviewed so
we can tell that he's making no prior
you it also asked Cayley first oh that's
the same question are you confident
Kelley I think the dam now is broken now
that it's okay and we're gonna get the
Pfizer applications and we're gonna get
the gate info and we're gonna get the
302s we're gonna get the five buckets
that John Solomon always talks about
absolutely we're going to get all of
that Shawn I'm confident that America is
waking up to this you've been on this
from the very beginning on your show the
molar reports about to come out we're
going to find no collusion no wrongdoing
on the part of the president Zero
probable cause to open an investigation
into the president after millions of
pages of documents reviewed and you were
right all along we should have been
looking at the FBI and the DOJ under
Obama you believe in your heart
congressman with all we now know and all
this we're not gonna have a cascade of
new information in the days and weeks
ahead that those people that tried that
first rigged the investigation into
Hillary tried to fix a presidential
campaign in this country and rigged the
outcome and tried to bludgeon the winner
and undo that election with known lies
they were warned in August of 2016 will
they be held accountable I would like to
tell you yes Sean in my heart of heart I
don't believe so but I think the
American people figured it out well
that's why Hillary Clinton is not the
President of the United States so so the
people that rigged it we now know they
rigged the investigation they're gonna
get away with that I wish I could tell
you yes if it was up to you and me
and John Radcliffe and trey gowdy
another Jim Jordan yes they would be
legit but that's not the way it's going
to work we're gonna walk and I might as
well shred the Constitution then I might
as well say there's no equal justice or
application of our laws I agree with you
it drives me nuts that's why I'm on this
network night after night talking about
it's why I was in Congress powder my
nose you don't break you know and I got
to tell you they have got to prosecute
these people well we'll see I I am
hearing that more is happening than we
know
I hope my source is right so far we
haven't been wrong